はい、どうも～
こんにちは、はい
というわけで、今日はですね
ちょっとドッキリみたいなことをしてみようと思います
というわけで今回のドッキリのメインゲストである私、骨、人骨模型,すなわち
だいすけでーす、よろしくー
はい、というわけで、今回なんですけども、私
人骨模型が、はじめしゃちょーの後輩に
ドッキリを仕掛けてみようと思います
これ疲れるからやめよう
ていう訳で、僕が
子供のころからずっとほしかった
骸骨を今回、買うことができました。人骨模型です
だいすけ、かわいいねぇ、キーホルダーにもできそうですよね
はい、というわけで今回こちらの人骨模型の
だいすけを使って後輩に
とあるドッキリを仕掛けてみようと思います
よろしくな
だいすけ：よろしく
はいというわけなんですけども
実験の方法としては
見てわかると思うんですけども
けっこうね
身長が同じくらいなんですよ
だいすけと俺が
な？だいすけ：うん
だいすけと僕身長が結構同じくらいなんで
僕の私服をだいすけが着ます。だいすけ：うん。
後輩が僕のうちに上がってくると
上がってきた瞬間だいすけに帽子をかぶせてると
多分骸骨ってばれないんすよ
なので今回は
マサキが家に上がってきて
マサキが僕と思って実際にこの子に話しかけたら
なんとびっくり
実は私だいすけだったというドッキリでご　ざいま〜〜〜〜〜す
はいというわけで早速ちょっと準備をしていきましょう
まずは子の子に服を着させてあげます
うわ
足が折れちゃう
だいすけ　ナイスダイスケ
待って
う”あ〜だいすけ〜
ほぼ僕と同じ体格の骨です
僕の骨は多分大体こんな感じです
だいすけ　しっかりこっちを見なさい
今からお前は頑張るんだぞ
だいすけ：はい
どうしよひとまず
ひとまず服を着させます
よしいいこいいこいいこだよ
うわっ！パンツが引っかかった！！
はい！バンザイ！
もう、もう来るんっすよね。もうすぐ。
マジ、急いだ方がいい！これ！
後、こっち向けっ！
うわ、これでもヤバいなぁ。
鎖骨も何も、
骨が見えちゃってるよ！
だいすけお前、これやべえ。バレちゃうかもな？
鎖骨を隠しましょう
スッゲー引っかかるなぁ、おまえ
これ、骨折れちゃうよ？
ＯＫ～！だいすけ腕できたよ～！
だいすけ、肩幅なくね？
あ、意外と悪くないかも！
俺がよく着る服を着させよう！
だいすけ！！
スタジャンだ！
スタジャン着よう！スタジャン！
結構、俺っぽいぞ？服装は
おっけ
ごめんね、もうすぐ終わります！
了解。
ほい！じゃねえ～
は～い
はっはっは
もう、来る！！
ヤベ、ちょっと骨ばれちゃうな！これ
俺っぽいぞ？？
完全に俺じゃん！！
もうほぼ、完成系です！
あっ、耳ないじゃん？？
待って、だいすけ耳ないからマスク出来ないよ！！
そっちの扉から入ってくるから
ちょ、バレないように
あ、パッとみ俺だわ！
パッとい完全俺だこれ！！
また不自然な足の出っ張りとか無くせば
これ分かんないしょ？？
これ俺だよ！！パッとみ
ちょっと見て
一応ターゲットが入ってくるルートは
こう上って来てのれんを潜ってこうなるんすよ！
で、これです！！
パッとみ俺でしょ？この服装とか
ほらもう、ここまでだよ俺！
ああ、俺だ！！
完全に俺だ！
で、ここまで来たら
ぎゃーーー！！
ってなって欲しい
はい、という訳で僕の骸骨との影分身の術
形は出来たので、実際にターゲットを呼んでみましょう！
では、行こう！！
もしもし～？
はぁい上にいる
ウォ～イ
何者って思ったし！
えぇ！待って
えっだって俺かと思わんかった？？
一瞬思ったけど、
あっ、よっぽど疲れてるんだなぁ～
おめえって最低！！
ダメかぁ～、おかしいな
絶対間違えると思ったのにな